[Music]
we have some special guests in studio
Jim oh that's right we have some
representatives from a growing program
at the scene we was chess club chess
cops and there with Maurice indeed an
exciting program chess cop said we
ourselves attended the inaugural
celebration of we have with us Jeff
hoots who is lieutenant Jeff foods that
is 27 year old veteran of the st. Louis
Police Department and also Pat Dolan who
was the head of the PLO gentlemen
welcome to the show thanks for citing
things you guys are doing tell us a
moment about the police athletically
so the Police Athletic League consists
of myself sergeant and seven police
officers were countywide program and we
work in areas where we have some
underprivileged youth that might not
have the opportunity to compete in
certain athletic events so my officers
and myself we go to these different
schools and areas that participate in
the program and we offer football
softball baseball chests which is
growing for us ballet you name it
swimming fishing all different kinds of
sports and tell us what are your plans
for the future of the PA oh as you
implement the programs down the road
well we continue to evolve with
partnerships such as the Chess Club
we've other school districts we have
certain school districts we're involved
with over getting into more school
districts and larger parts of the county
it's not concentrated in this one area
we're spreading out or do more field
trips and they're just fun interesting
thing the kids like to we've taken them
on trips of the different areas Chicago
to Civil Rights Museum in Memphis things
like that so we're playing and hopefully
with the funding to get some more
funding and then we'll be able to take
one more trips and and enhance the
programs any way we can so it sounds
wonderful oh it is and I know we got one
special program that's dear to our heart
tell us about a chess summer camp so
guys have done yes so we did a chess
camp up at a Jennings area earlier this
year and then we wanted to expand the
program down to our South County area
and
so we teamed up with the local chess
club here and we started this program
we're cops enhancing skills with where
the children and the youth would play
our police officers and chess now we see
some b-roll there of that happening and
looks like you right there got your 15
seconds of fame yeah but the kids is all
smiles you must really really warm your
heart to be a part of yeah it does when
when a police officer can interact with
the youth and a positive environment and
let them sit and actually just have
one-on-one conversation this normal
conversation it you know makes me feel
good as a police officer and I know it
makes that child feel welcomed as well
absolutely we were thrilled to be at
that event and Pat tell me you have we
have seen a challenge here in st. Louis
a lot of people remember Ferguson almost
is the flashpoint and the one thing they
do remember and they don't see a lot of
the other programs that are happening I
know you have some initiative that
you've started the restore program tell
us about that well it started with the
United States division of Health and
Human Services and it moved down to our
st. Louis County Public Health
Department so along with them it's a
multidisciplinary grants so we have
school districts involved we're part of
the components of it or our end of it as
the police and police department along
with the higher education as obsolete
university was already st. Louis and SIU
Carbondale when they moderate and take
all the statistics from where they meet
with the kids and interview them and see
how they're interacting with the police
and air meet with the police and slowly
basically just follow the program and
it's a four-year program so it does
allow us to have some funding so we can
do some of these programs so it's it's
been a win-win for this region here we
are the largest so far it's a national
program but we lead the nation and
those kids that are participating in a
police officer so it's been very very
good program wonderful to hear that's in
that initiative tell me we know all this
chess going on here in st. Louis do you
play chess I am a beginner did years ago
but I have to brush up all right kids
you the kids ought to take you on
everyone a piece of you so be honest
with you I had never played chess until
we did the program up in Jennings and I
watched Jenna and yourself play multiple
people at one time and I was amazed by
that and I like to strategic thinking
you have to do with that so I learned at
our chess camp just recently down in
South County that we hosted and now I
have a chess board in my office with
chess pieces and I'm I bought and I love
it the kids meeting you yes well thank
you so much for all the work you do a
really appreciative of lieutenant Jeff
boots and head of the PAI Pat Dolan
doing wonderful work here in st. Louis
yeah I just wanted to say Jeff you're
gonna have to
you don't look intimidating at the board
I saw that photo and boy you're scaring
anybody with your day I'm gonna have to
brush up on that one but thank you
gentlemen for all you do that's
wonderful
[Music]
you